let's do some examples comparing
absolute values so let's say we were to
ask ourselves how
negative 9 the absolute value of
negative 9 i should say how that
compares how that compares to the
absolute value of let me think of a good
number let's say the absolute value of
negative 7. so let's think about this a
little bit and let's think about what
negative 9 looks like or where it is on
the number line where negative seven is
on the number line let's see what the
absolute values mean and then we should
probably be able to do this comparison
so there's a couple of ways to think
about it one is you can draw them on the
number line
so if this is zero if this is negative 7
and then this is negative 9 right over
here now when you take the absolute
value of a number you're really saying
how far is that number from zero whether
it's to the left or to the right of zero
so for example negative nine is nine to
the left of zero so the absolute value
of negative nine is exactly nine this
evaluates to nine
negative seven is exactly 7 to the left
of 0
is exactly 7 to the left of 0. so the
absolute value of negative 7 is positive
7.
and so if you were to compare 9 and 7
this is a little bit more
straightforward 9 is clearly is clearly
greater than
7. and if you ever get confused with the
greater than or less than symbols just
remember that the symbol is larger on
the left hand side so that's the greater
than side if i were to write this and
this is actually also a true statement
if you took up these without the
absolute value signs it is also true
that negative 9 is less than
is less than negative 7. notice the
smaller side is on the smaller number
and so that's the interesting thing
negative 9 is less than negative 7 but
they're absolute value since negative 9
is further to the left of 0 it is the
absolute value of negative 9 which is 9
is greater than the absolute value of
negative 7. another way to think about
it is if you take the absolute value of
a number it's really just going to be
the positive version of that number so
if you took the absolute value of 9 you
take the absolute value of 9 that equals
9 or the absolute value of negative 9.
that is also equal to 9. when we think
of it visually that's because both of
these numbers are exactly 9 away from 0.
this is 9 to the right of 0 and this is
9 to the left of 0. let's do a few more
of these
so let's say that we wanted to compare
we wanted to compare the absolute value
of 2 to the absolute value of 3.
well the absolute value of a positive
number is just going to be that same
value 2 is 2 to the right of 0. so this
is just going to evaluate to 2 and then
the absolute value of 3 that's just
going to evaluate to 3. it's actually
pretty straightforward so 2 is clearly
this the smaller number here and so we
clearly get 2 is less than 3 or the
absolute value of 2 is less than 3. so
we have a less than right over here
let's say you wanted to compare you
wanted to compare i'm trying to find a
suitable color the absolute value of
negative 8
to the absolute value of 8.
well one way to think about it is that
they are both eight away from zero this
is eight to the left of zero this is
eight to the right of zero so both of
these things evaluate to eight absolute
value of negative eight is eight
absolute value of eight is eight and so
clearly eight is equal to eight let me
do a couple of more examples let's say i
had i wanted to compare the absolute
value of negative one and i want to
compare that to
positive 2.
so the absolute value of negative 1 is
just the positive version of 1 which is
or it's just a positive version of
negative 1 which is just which is just
1. so 1 is clearly less than 2 or the
other way to think about it the absolute
value of negative 1 is clearly less than
2.